- Will any player ever match me?
Well, he would have to be some sort of freak.
Huh? Whoo!
- Ohh.
- Is this the moon? Of course I'd win the space race.
- [Old-school announcer:] Welcome to an arena not only
of sight and sound, but of mind.
On one side, fresh off his 100-point game:
1962 Wilt Chamberlain.
- [Modern announcer:] Versus the Greek Freak himself:
2021 Giannis Antetokounmpo.
- Wow, was that a wormhole? God bless America, man.
- So, they had to get a guy from the future to challenge me?
[chuckles]
- [Old-school announcer:] And Wilt's on pace to beat
his 100-point record.
- I have so many questions. 20,000?
- [Old-school announcer:] Wilt to the rack...he throws it down!
Wilt is just too dominant.
- You can't stop the best scorer of all time.
- Actually, I think it's Jordan for average and Kareem for total.
- I don't care who those suckers are, I could play in any era.
- Maybe we could update the court then?
- [Modern announcer:] Oh, thank God.
Get this man some kicks so he doesn't look like a hipster!
- Whoa, you copped.
- Wh...wh...what the hell is this?
- Sorry, sir.
Learning new things is hard.
You know each American city has its own type of pizza?
That's so many types!
My turn!
- [Modern announcer:] Giannis with the spin. Ooh, baby,
he's too clean!
- [Old-school announcer:] Unbelievable.
- [Modern announcer:] Ay, Giannis is a cheat code, finishing with a filthy Eurostep.
- Aha! A communist.
- [Old-school announcer:] From way downtown!
Wilt collects the rebound...now driving the baseline
...and he slams it home!
- Game point. I am the best at everything.
- [Old-school announcer:] Oh, foul. Wilt to the line.
- It's my only weakness, OK?
- The trick to foul shots is to take forever.
You'll get it.
- [Old-school announcer:] And Wilt finally plays some D.
- Amazing block, man! Oh, sorry, foul again.
You got it this time.
- [Modern announcer:] Giannis so humble. God, we all love him.
- Humble...being humble works?
- [Modern announcer:] And Wilt is shooting granny style?!
Ugh, this is cringe, just take the L.
- [Old-school announcer:] Yeah, he's no hero of mine anymore.
- [Chamberlain:] God, I hope Bill Russell ain't watching this.
- [Old-school announcer:] And Wilt wins with what I think is a career-low 11 points!
- It's hard for a man like me to say this, but thank you.
I will never forget you.
- No, it was my pleas-
- I'm talkin' to the shoes.
- Yeah, this is a fine matchup, but
what about MJ vs. LeBron?
- Portalcorn here, get your portalcorn!
- Ooh, ooh! Get us some!
- Yo, how much for a quark?
- Uh, a billion parsecs.
- This is damn highway robbery.
You know, this is why people just subscribe
below and don't come to the game.
- Trying to make a living, buddy!